Right. Rita Ali, how you doing?
>> Um, just start off. I'm here to learn
the verses I'm going to bring up.
There's probably a deeper explanation to
them, so that you probably know and I
don't. So, just want to get that out
here.
>> Fair enough.
>> Um, okay. So, it was two two different
points that you want to focus on. One
was the Allah of Islam is not God. And
the second was that the God of the Bible
or Jesus is um is not the most high.
Like those two, right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So, I'll start with and I'm
assuming that we're going by like the
Christian definition of what God is. Is
that fair?
>> Just you know the the one creator of all
things, all knowing, all powerful, you
know.
>> Got you. Okay. So, starting with the
first point, um a love of Islam is not
God. So the first thing is I I I used
the description of God given in Isaiah
40:28 which is the Lord it was four
criterias. Number one the Lord is the
everlasting God. Number two the creator
of the ends of the earth. Number three
he doesn't grow tired or weary. And
number four his understanding non-conf.
So that was Isaiah 40:28. Um and and
then um so then I went to the Quran
verse 2255. Um I don't know if you want
to pull it up.
>> How long have you been a Muslim?
>> Um all my life, but I'm trying to learn.
The truth is out there somewhere.
Wherever it is, I'll leave everything
for it. So
>> that's good to hear. Um it's okay. So go
ahead and uh
>> Yeah. So then I went to Quran 225. if
you want to open that up so you could
read along with me.
>> And
>> um
>> what was the first one that you quoted
in the Bible? What was that verse?
>> Isaiah 40:28.
>> Isaiah 40:28. Okay. And then in in the
Quran, you're quoting chapter 2 verse
>> 255.
>> And the reason why I chose these two is
because the descriptions like almost
aligned perfectly. So
>> the first criteria given in Isaiah 40
was he's the everlasting God. In 22 255
it says he is ever living.
>> Okay.
>> Um and then in the second criteria is
the creator of all of the earth. Um 2255
says everything in the earth's
everything the heavens and the earth and
their creation belongs to him. Um and
then the third criteria was he doesn't
grow tired or weary. Uh and then 2255
says he doesn't grow drowsy or sleepy.
And then uh the fourth criteria was his
understanding is beyond our grasp. And
then 22 255 explicitly says no one can
grasp his knowledge. So my conclusion
based on that is that since the
description of Allah and Islam aligns
perfectly with the description of God in
Isaiah 40:28, the Allah of Islam is his
description is God.
>> Okay. All right. I see your line of
reasoning uh that they share similar
qualities. So therefore he fits the
criteria of being God. I understand. Um
so this is what this would be I I want
to ask you this. So [snorts] would you
agree then along with this when it says
he's the creator of everything and the
everlasting one that that includes that
he is
>> he's all powerful.
>> That is our criteria. Okay.
>> Um and to be all powerful means that he
is self- sustaining. He does not need
any help to do anything. Um if he needed
help to do anything uh outside of
himself then he would not be all
powerful and therefore not God. Correct.
>> Um yeah he's all powerful he could do
everything.
>> Okay. All right. So with Islam then let
me ask you this from what you know
>> uh is Allah capable of having a son if
he wanted to?
>> Um he's capable of doing everything that
doesn't limit him. So everything within
his nature. So I'd say that having a son
goes against his nature because
attributing human qualities to God which
limits him and anything
>> what do you mean by human what do you
mean by human qualities
>> having a son essentially because then
you're creating like another person with
divinity and like sharing divinity with
someone else limits you because you
can't have two fully um infinite powers
because it's a mathematical
contradiction type
>> but that wouldn't necessarily be two
infinite powers. It would be it would be
like it would be one just with two
persons that share that infinite power.
>> So if if I'm going with you though, let
me grant you that you're what you're
saying, you know, that he couldn't do
this because it would mean that um his
power is limited and that and that's
kind of an internal contradiction if
there's another person who has some
infinite type of power.
>> Sorry, my my volume cut out for a
second. Can you just repeat that
sentence? Sorry.
>> Yeah. So I was saying I was go let's
let's if I'm going with you that it
wouldn't it would it would basically be
an internal contradiction to Allah to be
able to have a son which would mean that
like it's um the sun is another source
of infinite power other than Allah. Is
that what you're saying?
>> Um yeah essentially because it's like
dividing up God.
>> Okay. All right. So I want I want to
show you a verse to get your thoughts on
it. Okay. And it's chapter 39:4.
>> 39:4.
>> Okay. Sorry. Just give me a second.
>> Yep. Take your time, man. Ain't no rush
here. While he's getting that, guys,
make sure everybody hits the like
button. We got 3,000 people watching on
YouTube. 381 watching on uh Tik Tok
right now. So, everybody make sure you
smash the like button. Let's get up to
3,000 likes.
>> Okay. Yeah, I'm on.
>> You are. All right.
>> So, go go go ahead. What does it say?
Um, had it been God's will to have off
offspring, he would have chosen whatever
he willed of his creation. Glory be to
him. He is God, the one, the supreme.
>> So, this says that Allah could have a
son if he wanted to, right?
>> Um, could I add something real quick?
>> Sure.
>> So,
son, I feel like it could be used
ambiguously. It doesn't have to mean
biologically through beginning. And you
would agree that like for example in the
Bible it calls many people including
like Solomon and Adam the sons of God
but it doesn't mean it within a literal
biological sense or like beetting sense
like Jesus rather in terms of endearment
and u like signification. So I feel like
you could apply that same ruling here
and it doesn't we don't have to take the
literal um biological meaning of sun and
rather through endearment.
>> Yeah. Well, um, with this it actually
says it says offspring, right? So, which
is the word wid, which actually means a
son from yourself, like your own your
very own son. It's not a metaphorical
son or forget if it's an actual son of
yours. So, um, this is what it's talking
about. It's saying that he can actually
have offspring. He if he wanted to, he
could have offspring
>> with any of his creation if he chose to.
Um, so what I'd say to that is I'm
ignorant on the matter. It's a good
point. I have to do personal research on
that because um I don't want to speak of
things I'm not knowledgeable. Good. Fair
enough. I'm definitely going to look
into it.
>> Fair enough. Fair enough.
>> Looking into the reasoning behind it,
but that's a fair point by you.
>> Yep. Fair enough. Fair enough. Okay. So,
there's there's another layer to this.
Okay. There's another layer to this. All
right. So, um, because with this saying
that Allah could have offspring if he
wanted to, um, and he could just choose
from any of his creation. Well, then
this kind of goes against this idea
that, well, if Allah was he he can't
have a son because then that would, I
guess, limit him or contradict his own
nature or something like that. Maybe he
can have a son and he can have offspring
in a way that doesn't maybe it doesn't
contradict his nature. Excuse me. Sorry,
I'm eating protein shake. um that
doesn't contradict his nature.
>> Um now here here will be my next
question. Okay.
>> Um wait just before we move on could I
just add one thing.
>> Yeah.
>> I feel like the fact that it says he
would have chosen one of his like
creation to be his offspring that like
completely contradicts the point of
offspring be being biological
because it's saying like he's choosing
from already existing creation
>> which his offering.
Yeah, there there's an interpretation
that when he says he could have chosen
from what he creates whatever he willed,
um that he's talking about what he would
have an offspring with. So it's it's not
that the what he could have chosen from
whatever he created would have been the
son. Oh, that could be that's a valid
interpretation. I think there's another
one that's that suggests that it's
talking about him getting with someone
to have a son.
>> Okay. Yeah.
Well, that sounds like kind of bizarre.
Like
>> it does,
>> but but I'm I'm going to show you why
it's it's not totally bizarre. Let me
show you why. Okay.
>> So So if you go to chapter 6, verse 101.
>> Yeah. Just give me a second. So repeat
6101 you said.
>> Yeah. 6
101.
>> Gotcha. Give me a sec. Sorry. So, like I
agree with you and firsthand that that
sounds a little sounds a little crazy,
but because of this verse in light of
this one, it it's not all that off.
>> Okay. Yeah, I have it open. Uh, you want
me to read it?
>> Yes, sir.
>> Okay. Uh, he is the originator of the
heavens and earth. How could he have
children when he has no mate? He created
all things and has perfect knowledge of
everything.
>> Right. So, do you see how it says that,
you know, he's Allah? He's he's the he's
the greatest. He says, "Um,
>> all right. So, in the meantime, while
you were gone, I did open up the for the
verse for 394."
>> 394. Okay.
>> And I'm just gonna
>> Which which one?
>> Uh, Nisan.
>> Nisam. Who's that?
>> Um, I'm a Shia. That's why. So, that's
>> Oh, you're a Shia.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Oh, okay. Interesting. All right. Go
ahead. What do you say?
>> Um, so that's like our main one
basically. It's like the
>> Okay. Thank you for that. I didn't know
that.
>> So, it summarizes it makes two main
points. First off, it says that um by
God it appearing
it appears that it it's meant merely as
an honorific status rather than a
metaphysical one. That was the first
point made. And the second point made
was the word that was used uh at the
beginning for had it been
it is a conditional clause used to show
an impossibility. So those were the two
points that were made.
>> Yeah. So there's um it doesn't make
sense to me if I'm going to critically
think about that. I hear what he's
saying. It says had it been or if Allah
had willed to do this, it says he could.
So, it doesn't seem like it's an
impossibility when it explicitly says he
could do it if he wanted to, you know.
So, that yeah, that that doesn't really
add up to me. Um, but as far as like an
honorific title or like having an
honorific
um relationship with him, again, I don't
I don't see that based on the text, but
I do understand that that is an
interpretation. It's an interpretation.
Um, I think you could go either way. My
my thing is like even if we're let's
let's say that this is only talking like
um figuratively like you're you're his
offspring or his son in a figurative
sense not that you are begotten from
him. Um, in 6101, it demonstrates that
Allah could have a son if he had a mate,
but he
>> Well, I feel like there's a difference
between saying he could have a son
without or if he had a mate and saying
that he doesn't have a mate and he also
won't have a son because because he
doesn't have a mate. So, I feel like
like there's a big difference between
saying he could have a mate and the
reason that he doesn't have a son is
because he doesn't have that mate and
saying that he like I'm sorry like it's
>> well yeah let's let's think through this
really quick. So it says how can right
meaning so it's talking about his
ability.
>> How can he have a son when he doesn't
have a mate right? So this is saying
that Allah can't have a son unless he
has a mate to have a son with. So
>> but there's a difference between saying
like unless and because like I feel like
this verse doesn't explicitly give the
possibility of him him having a mate.
It's just showing how um unlogical the
idea of him him having a son is. Well, I
I can I can agree that it's not saying
that it's necessarily possible for him
to have a mate
>> um or that he will have a mate or
whatever,
>> but it is it is it's highlighting
whether or not he can have a son or not.
It's saying that he would need a mate to
do it.
>> Now, is it possible for him to have a
mate? Probably, probably not. Who knows?
Probably not. Which is why which is
which is why he can't have a son. That's
what I would say that it's impossible
for him to have a mate. Therefore, it's
impossible for him to have a son because
he can't have a mate.
>> So, would you claim that these two
verses explicitly show that Allah does
have the ability of having a son? Would
you claim that?
>> I I would Yes. At least 6 chapter 6
verse 101 uh 394. Yeah, I I would say
that.
>> But you would also agree that there are
interpretations that would resolve the
issue. I don't I don't think the
interpretation resolves it if it goes
against what the text says. That's
that's my issue. Like I can hear an
interpretation, right? If it doesn't
line up with what is being said, like
for example, the what you shared
earlier, the interpretation that this is
a a conditional impossibility, it
literally says explicitly he could do it
if he wanted. So it's not impossible. So
that's a that's an interpretation that
like literally contradicts the text. So,
um, so I'm not I'm saying that there are
interpretations. I don't think that
they're valid based on
>> Okay. But would you say there's So, like
I just want to focus on the
interpretation, the one that makes the
most sense to me, which was that uh it's
an honorific status. That's the
interpretation I want to focus on
because the other ones don't really make
that much sense like the conditional and
profit and possibility and whatever. Um
so um you'd say that like the interpreta
so can you like tell me why the
interpretation is false that it's an
honorific status
>> sure because this is one is talking
about an offspring the word wid is used
as a physical son or like a literal son
that's how it's used throughout the
Quran wid it's an your actual son so to
suddenly say oh well this actually being
used as honorific doesn't really make
sense at it's ad hoc it's out nowhere.
Secondly, the context is Allah is um
he's um refuting this idea that he has
children. Like they're saying he has
children in in both uh context in
chapter 39:4 and 6101 if you read the
verses prior and after he's addressing
people who are saying he has children,
right? So and and when he says it, this
is his rebuttal. His rebuttal is if
Allah had willed to take a son he could
have chosen from whatever he created
whatever he willed but exalted is he
above that right he is Allah the one
prevailing so he's above doing that he's
he that this is his rebuttal
[clears throat]
>> so saying that this is just an honorific
title or position someone can have um is
not it doesn't match with the context if
that makes sense.
>> Okay. Um, yeah, honestly, fair point.
Um, I have to do more research on it.
I'm ignorant on the matter. So, that's a
good point. And then let's say we did
move on from that premise. What's the
next premise that would continue the
debate?
>> Absolutely. So, the next premise is that
okay, um, he can't have a son by
himself. He would need help to do it,
which would mean he's not all powerful
and therefore not God.
>> Okay, got it. So the line of reasoning
would be that he has the ability to
create a son, but then it and then 6101
says that he doesn't have a mate and
therefore he can't have a son, meaning
that he needs a mate to have son.
>> Correct.
>> Okay, fair point. Um, I'd have to look
into that. I'm going to be honest. I'm
ignorant on the matic.
>> Definitely have to look into like the
context of all the verses. We don't I
don't want to take up too much time from
the stream and whatnot.
>> No, bro. That this this is what we do
this for, man. We we try to find honest
people we can talk to and build with,
you know. So,
>> um with with somebody like you with you
you've come humbly, you know what I'm
saying? You're being reasonable. Um
yeah, you I I could talk to somebody
like you all day and any day. So, I'm
I'm serious, man. You watch you'll see
if I don't know if you're going to stick
around and watch the Okay. Well, you
you're going to see what I'm what I have
to deal with on a daily basis, man.
>> Um but yeah, so is is that is that all
you wanted or did you want to ask about
Jesus? It was the and then because that
was the first part the Allah of is God
and then the second part was Jesus is
the the God of the Bible or Jesus is the
most high.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> So I'm also basing this argument on well
there's two proofs for Jesus or the God
of the Bible not being the most high.
The first one was based on the
description in Isaiah 40:28.
Um
my the point the point that I wanted to
give is that there were two criterias in
Isaiah 40:28. One was that he doesn't
grow tired or weary. Um and the second
was that his understanding is infinite.
His knowledge is infinite. Um so my
counter against that was Genesis 9:13-15
which was the covenant of the rainbow in
order to um remind God and there could
be a deeper meaning to meaning to this
that I don't know of so if you want to
enlighten me share but basically what I
would say is that if God did need
reminding provided in this ver these
verses from Genesis Genesis 9 from 13 to
15 then it would contradict two of the
criterias given in Isaiah 40:28. One
that his knowledge is infinite because
if you need reminding then your
knowledge isn't truly infinite at all
times and two that uh the not growing
weary because if you need reminding then
your knowledge grows weary. So those
would be that that's basically the first
proof for the God of the Bible not being
the most high.
>> Yeah. So interesting. So in Genesis 9
where it talks about how God is going to
be how God is going to remember his the
promise he makes by the sign of the
rainbow right this is it's figurative
speech communicating communicating God's
uh promise and design how he will always
remember like for example there's a
there's verses in the Bible that says um
how God is going to forgive your sins
wipe away your sins and remember them no
more, right? That doesn't mean that he
forgot what you did. It's just that it's
not going to count against you anymore,
right? So, in the same way, um this this
this promise as a reminder is is just a
um a concrete stance with God that he'll
never flood the earth again. Not that he
forgot what he said he's not going to
do. It's just it's just emphasizing his
promise.
>> Okay. So you just say it's figurative
basically.
>> Yeah.
>> The interpretation would be that it's
figurative.
>> Like like like an anthropomorphic
language like being applied to God.
>> That's a big word. Can you repeat it?
>> An anthropomorphic language like when
you like if I said like this my car was
mad at me today. It slowed down on the
road, you know. Okay.
>> Cars don't get mad.
>> Okay. So yeah, it was basically
figurative. That's the interpretation
for Got it. Understood.
>> Does Does that make sense though? Does
it flow? Yeah, I mean I'd say close. And
then also because a thought just
randomly like appeared. I wasn't
thinking about it before, but you said
that was like the word for offspring. Um
>> yeah, of offspring or son like as an
actual son. Yeah.
>> Um the word which literally means a son
of like when the Quran says Ben is the
children of Isel which is Jacob. The
wordben is more so used as like literal
um son. The word I feel like could be
used as either while is like the
definite 100% biological literal.
>> Well, how about this? How about the next
time you come,
>> let's let's let's explore that and see
what we find.
>> I'll do research on that. Also, do you
like post your uh schedules like ahead
of time? So, I'm I'm live every So,
you'll you'll if you go to my like
actual YouTube page, it'll tell you my
live stream schedule. So, I'm I'm live
every Monday, Wednesday, Friday at 5:00
p. p.m. Eastern Standard Time. So,
>> and it's like a different debate topic
every time.
>> You have different topics every time.
However, with guests that have I've, you
know, come before, we'll continue where
we left off if they want to do that. So,
like with you, we could continue where
we left off today.
>> All right. Gotcha. Okay. And Yeah. And
then moving on to the second proof, um
it was that um so first off, uh 1st
Samuel 15:29,
uh it says that um God is the glory of
Israel. Uh he does not lie or regret,
for he is not a human being that he
should change his mind.
>> And then Numbers 23:19 also says um God
is not son of man that he should regret.
Mhm.
>> Specifically the point of regretting,
right? So one example I gave from the
Bible was Genesis 66
>> where um it says the Lord regretted that
he had made human beings on earth and
his heart was deeply troubled. So
there's a criteria in the Bible given
that God doesn't regret
>> but then also the Bible also says that
he regretted putting human beings on
earth. So that would be the second
proof.
>> Okay. Yeah. So again, it'll be more so
the same thing. This anthropomorphic
language being applied to God, regret or
uh it's it's an expression of his
displeasure with human with human beings
that he made.
>> So it's not that God is saying he made a
mistake or you know that he's you know
no [clears throat] he's deeply he's
deeply uh displeased with man's actions
which is why he's going to deal with it
differently. Oh, there's something going
on on your mic. Sorry, it's the heater.
My bad. Sorry
while you're talking. Heater. Heater.
>> Oh, okay.
>> I'll mute myself when you talk.
>> Yeah. Okay. Yeah, sure. So, so with
numbers with numbers 23:19,
this is uh this is what the verse says
in full and the context makes it clear
what it's saying about God really quick.
So he says in 23:19
it says it says uh here it is for God is
not a man that he should lie nor a son
of man that he should change his mind.
Has he said and will he not do it? Or
has he spoken and will he not fulfill
it? Right? So what this is what this is
talking about is
um God not lying or changing his mind
going back on his word like how man goes
back on his word. So that's why he
finishes off it says has he said and
will he not do it? Will he not do what
he said he's going to do or has he
spoken and will he not fulfill it? So,
the context of Numbers 23:19,
God is not a man that he should lie, nor
is he uh a son of man that he should
change his mind or repent or whatever
like that. It's that he he's not fickle
and and a liar like man is. When he says
something, he's going to do it, right?
When he promises something, he's going
to fulfill it. Does that make sense?
>> Yeah, I got you. But just one thing I'd
like to add, like I was more um
accepting of the figurative um like
interpretation for the last uh proof
because like you gave an example where
it was used in another part of the Bible
figuratively.
>> Mhm.
>> So would you have like an an example
where this specific word of like regret
or changing your mind was used
figuratively in the Bible?
>> Are you talking about Genesis 9?
>> Yeah. like the word used in Genesis 66.
Oh yeah, in Genesis 9 when you said the
like specific word about remembered, you
brought another verse from the Bible
where it was used in a figurative sense.
So I was just wondering if you could if
the word for regret in Genesis 6, if
there was another example where that
that was used in a figurative sense in
the Bible.
>> Um I don't I don't have a I don't have
an example of that that comes to my
mind.
>> Yeah, I know. Very on the spot. I know.
Yeah, I don't I don't have a verse that
comes to my mind of of it being used in
that way, but um I I I just know that
when it comes to like so the context of
Numbers 23 and Genesis 9 are completely
two different contexts. One is dealing
with like Numbers is dealing with God's
character and his promise with Israel.
How he promised not to destroy them but
to preserve them. So he's not going to
go back on his word and lie like man
does. Genesis 9 is dealing with God's
displeasure with human beings and their
actions. And um so it has nothing to do
with necessarily him like making a
mistake, but it's it's it's
communicating his displeasure that he
has um with human beings, which is why
the next line says, "And his heart was
dis displeased with them."
>> Right.
>> Gotcha.
>> So Gotcha.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I hope that makes sense
because he's he's he the Bible talks
about how everything that God makes is
good and um and he gave man free will
and stuff like that and obviously
they're going to do if they do evil it's
going to be a displeasure to to him in
his sight. So um and then last last
thing um so I'm sure you're aware of the
story in Matthew 15 where like the
gentile woman came to Jesus and then he
initially said I was only spent as sent
to the like lost sheep of Israel.
>> Um in this case because we've already
established that God doesn't change his
mind. Um so in this case would this be
an example of Jesus changing his mind?
Cuz initially he told her no um I was
only sent to the lost sheep of Israel
and then afterwards even again she asked
again and then he said uh it's not right
for the to take food from the children
and throw it to dogs. And then finally
the third time he accepted and granted
her request.
>> Yeah. So one he never tells her no and
that's important. He never tells her no.
He just one he ignores her then two he
says I was only sent for the lost sheep
of Israel and then he gives the analogy
it's not good to give the bread of the
children to the dogs that the children
eat first then the puppies right um and
then like so what we see here is is her
faith is clearly being tested he's he's
testing her and he's doing this in front
of the an audience um uh showcasing her
faith So, her faith is just being
tested, that's all. Does that make
sense?
>> Yeah, I got you. Um, sorry. I I'd say
like you should probably move on cuz
there's a bunch of people in the chat
and they're saying like I have to take a
long time. So,
>> I don't care about them. But yeah, yeah,
we can continue next time.
>> Remember, you're we're we're on our own
time, man. Don't nobody tell us when
when we when we
>> got
uh thanks for having me. Um, and
hopefully we'll continue. It was nice
talking to you learn
>> talking to you as well, man. Take care
of yourself. Okay. Take care.